EVERY CASE.
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
THE REACTION IS THE HOST OF CR
T'S LEVINE TV, THE HOST RIGHT
HERE ON FOX NEWS CHANNEL, THE
NUMBER ONE SHOW ON SUNDAY NIGHT
BY FAR.
WE CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE, MARK
LIVE IN.
LET ME THROW IT RIGHT TO YOU.
I'VE BEEN DOING RADIO 30 YEARS,
I'VE BEEN AT THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL SINCE
OCTOBER 1996, IT'S NEVER BEEN
THIS AWFUL AND IT'S BEEN BAD A
LOT OF TIMES.
>> A COUPLE THINGS HERE, FIRST
OF ALL NOTICE THERE IS NO BLUE
DRESS HERE.
OUT OF THESE THREE ACCUSERS,
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE EYE
WITNESS.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE
CORROBORATING WITNESS, NOT A
SINGLE SHRED OF EVIDENCE SO
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE IN COMMON.
NO CASE.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY DOES
DEMOCRATIC THEY BELIEVE THAT
ONLY THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
NO DUE PROCESS AND NO
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE BECAUSE
I HAVE TO MAKE THAT CASE.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE LAWYERS AND
OPERATIVES, THE SENATOR IS ALL
SCHEMING IN THE SHADOWS, THEY
COME UP WITH NOTHING TANGIBLE OR
CONCRETE.
THE REASON THEY BLOW THIS OFF AS
A COURT OF LAW IS BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW TOTALITARIANS THINK.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT MAKE
ACCUSATIONS, AND THIS ISN'T
ABOUT WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
THERE ARE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
OF WOMEN OUT THERE MANY OF THEM
WATCHING YOUR SHOW.
MY WIFE, MY MOTHER, MY DAUGHTER,
MY STEPDAUGHTER, MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW AND SO FORTH WHO
DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN WHO FIND THIS ENTIRE
SPECTACLE, IT'S A
ROMAN COLOSSEUM AND THEY ARE
THROWING THEM TO THE LINES.
LIBERALS DON'T SPEAK TO WOMEN.
DID BILL CLINTON SPEAK FOR ALL
THE WOMEN HE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED?
I DON'T THINK SO.
PEOPLE KEEP SAYING BRETT
KAVANAUGH HAD SIX FBI BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS.
HOW MANY BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS DID MS. FORD
HAVE?
ZERO.
WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER ACCUSERS?
HOW MANY BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS DID THEY HAVE?
ZERO.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING TO ME THAT
ALL THINGS LEFT-WING DEMOCRAT
LAWYERS WHO REPRESENT THESE
ACCUSERS, THEY KNOW WHERE THE
MONTGOMERY COUNTY POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS AND THEY HAVEN'T
WALKED A SINGLE ONE OF THEIR
CLIENTS INTO THAT
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGHK
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGHV
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGHN
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGHU
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGHH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT AGAINST MR. CAVANAUGH.
THEY KEEP TALKING ABOUT THE FBI.
IF YOU KNOW WHERE IT IS, DON'T
YOU GO AHEAD AND FILE YOUR
COMPLAINTS THERE?
AND I WILL TELL YOU YOU WHY
BECAUSE THEN THE RULE OF LAW
ACTUALLY KICKS IN.
I'M STARTING TO WONDER ABOUT THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THEY ARE EITHER FILLED WITH
PERVERTS OR TOTALITARIANS, IT'S
ONE OR THE OTHER.
THEY ARE GLEEFUL ANTS EXCITING
AND SALIVATING ALL OVER THIS.
IT'S A DISGUSTING SPECTACLE.
AND, ANOTHER THING I WANT TO
MENTION WHICH IS THIS, THIS LADY
COMES FORWARD AND POLITICO
REPORTS HE DOESN'T BELIEVE A
WORD SHE SAYS.
MICHAEL AVENATTI IS BACK, THE
SLIP AND FALL LAWYER.
THE DEMOCRATS EMBRACE HIM AND
EMBRACE THE ARGUMENT.
MS. RAMIREZ DID NOT WANT TO COME
FORWARD.
THE DEMOCRATS STAFF GOES AND
FINDS HER AND DRAGS HER FORWARD,
AND AND I'VE NEVER UNDERSTOOD
THIS DR. FORD ISSUE.
SHE WANTED TO REMAIN PRIVATE SO
WHERE DID SHE GO TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST"?
NOW HERE'S THE THING.
I KEEP HEARING ALL OVER
TELEVISION, I WANT TO HEAR WHAT
DR. FORD HAS TO SAY.
OF COURSE, WE ALL WANT TO HEAR
WHAT DR. FORD HAS TO SAY.
SHE HAS A PhD AND AN
ALLEGATION AGAINST ANOTHER HUMAN
BEING.
EXAMINATION                    C
EXAMINATION                    O
EXAMINATION                    S
EXAMINATION                    E
EXAMINATION                    A
EXAMINATION                    I
EXAMINATION                    E
SHE NEEDS TO BE CROSSED
EXAMINATION                    D
AGGRESSIVELY.
AND THE FOUR PEOPLE SHE MENTIONS
SAY, THAT'S NOT TRUE.
MS. FORD NEEDS TO BE QUESTIONED
AND THOROUGHLY.
AND I WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO UNDERSTAND SOMETHING, THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS FROM BORK TO
CLARENCE THOMAS, AND THE REST UP
TO NOW, AS BEEN HIJACKED.
LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATS ON THIS
COMMITTEE, IT'S THE MOST RADICAL
BUNCH IMAGINABLE.
YOU HAVE JILL BRAND, EINSTEIN,
DURBIN, KAMALA HARRIS, BOOKER,
ALL FROM DARK BLUE STATES.
ONE PARTY STATES WHO ARE TRYING
TO APPEAL THE MOST RADICAL
CRAZIES IN THEIR PARTY.
WE NEED TO STAND UP TO THIS.
>> Sean: MARK 11, THANK YOU.